hello and welcome to zero plain awesome
I met KSA probably and played them so no
Natalia game okay yeah that's not the
most exciting opening ever but tell me
not much to do about it if you've gotten
before each five played in the first
place okay now it will be a little bit
more interesting because i'm going to
play age 65 this early age 3 gives black
this opportunity
this is really a serious imprecision
that white allowed this attack him play
d4 interesting I mean maybe I could have
taken it but g4 was far more consistent
okay pawn takes Knight eggs with a
pretty awkward pin on the night
the default power that deformed move was
interesting though getting some quick
potential call to play in the center
it's difficult now for him to move for
any of the nights and I don't think 95
yeah I don't think this is going to work
on so we had to do where to put this it
was first of all first of all before we
do anything else can I do something
simple but should be 398 cannot trap his
night unfortunately I came so 27 I think
it takes a ruger I will take on with
risa ok so here probably I should
probably move the rock and five ok
I upon 360 wants to play if i take on
you five for the sea going to do 90 for
something i can always return material
then
what is this actually it's got to minus
yeah two minor pieces for Queen again
something like 94 I just take so far too
much material okay here i can play
Bishop f2 or queen at five sorry unit
five should also do the trick maybe it
was easier to take on F to know that I
look at this probably mmm yeah probably
could have done that in some more
convincing way
yeah this sometimes happens at you you
have a tee reel up and somehow your God
gets down a little bit you don't relieve
look that much for the best moves
anyone's all of a sudden think some
things get a little bit more interesting
than they should stinking here and now
maybe here I want to Castle long i slor'
allowed to come still allowed to castle
right it kind of embarrassing yeah I can
cancel long
okay i know lets us once in 296 I'd i
have a check him
play is going to lose this on time very
Larkin check should we work you should
be able to pick up the night on g6 yeah
I do
you
no song moves yeah that check that we
sacrifice ultimately check to snort work
check check check um there is no method
of the night this should be six it's not
quite made but close and yeah how do i
meet here that's you for maybe like five
hits on time yeah it was the other way
of doing it ok I'm back over 2,300 at
least so how did this work out yeah he
played this early age 3 which I really
think is in precise of black has not
cancelled this age six and g5 idea is
very dangerous absolutely ok d4 it's
interesting I didn't really think about
taking on d4 that much maybe it is
possible but it is not what you usually
want to do to open up the center once
you have played re5 so it really doesn't
really relate at all to my play on the
king cider this already looks pretty bad
yeah I think this is better simply okay
and now he decided to to go for this the
other thing is if this Queen sac is not
working and I don't think it does then
um this is pretty much lost yeah the
black attack with ruchi 827 long he
cannot move both these nights it's very
difficult for him to stop fish already
gives black and minus three years
position this is pretty amazing I mean I
was thinking that black should almost
win but this is very harsh from the
engine yeah and the the Queen sec
doesn't work
yeah so this is not not really all that
difficult check check check Chad don't
castle it's the thing don't castle with
age 3 this it's not a good good line
okay well guys thanks for watching